[Musique]
un nouveau numéro de votre rendez vous
consacré à la présidentielle en france
32 mille france 2022 l'heure du choix
comme chaque soir à 20h15 heure de paris
avec vous je serai le gardien bonsoir
bonsoir marion j - 9 avant le premier
tour de la présidentielle est dans cette
dernière ligne droite les candidats à la
présidentielle met les bouchées doubles
pour convaincre et pour afficher leur
proximité avec les français alors quoi
de mieux que de se rendre sur les
marchés traditionnels lieux de
rencontres avec les électeurs et de
tractage aussi pour les militants
certains candidats ont commencé très tôt
ce matin avec plus ou moins de succès le
récap politique est signée florent au
dos et juillet à bouder
c'est l'histoire d'une claque historique
annoncé anne hidalgo le sait avec elle
le ps pourrait bien réalisé son pire
score à la présidentielle depuis des
décennies alors dans cette dernière
ligne droite elle compte plus que jamais
sur sa base
c'est ce moment où je demande aux
socialistes
qu'ils soient encartés ou de coeur de ne
pas raser les murs de pas baisser la
tête d'être fiers si nous n'avions pas
été là ce pays ne serait pas le même
déambulation sur le marché de
boulogne-sur-mer pour la socialiste
eric zemmour lui a choisi celui de
rungis le plus grand du pays l'occasion
de vanter comme nicolas sarkozy la
france qui se lève tôt
des marchés qui ont décidément la cote
en moselle marine le pen vise encore
emmanuel macron dans les sondages elle
s'en rapproche pas vraiment dans les
idées 'l'annonce qu'il est opposé à la
légitime défense qui est un concept dans
notre droit pénal depuis toujours et qui
est parfaitement légal tout ceci
démontre une grande fébrilité du
candidat sa campagne a permis la
victoire de la gauche quand on lui parle
de marché lui pense à georges son modèle
fabien roussel est convaincu du bien
fondé de sa candidature communiste
importe quand le parti communiste se
faisait 15 % oui le monde du travail
était plus fort et on avait des
conquêtes sociales donc vous pensez
qu'un candidat communiste peut être élu
président la république au 21ème siècle
mais je pense que la gauche peut gagner
une gauche dont le meilleur espoir
s'appelle aujourd'hui jean-luc mélenchon
l'insoumis l'assurent il a trois
adversaires
d'abord monsieur macron parce qu'il
incarne d'une manière assez directe il
ne s'en cache pas un ordre du monde qui
je crois est à bout de souffle deuxième
et après il ya les deux autres à madame
le pen et monsieur zemmour parce que là
aussi c'est le vieux monde qui évite les
grandes questions qui et pour qui sont
posés à l'humanité même pas citer
valérie pécresse est à marseille visite
nocturne dans les quartiers nord
gangrenée par les trafics en tous genres
et où les policiers se disent démunis
nous ont dit qu est ce qui vous laisse
était harcelé les dealers mais qu'il y
avait deux problèmes pas assez d'outils
celui de protection et pas assez de
sanctions avec des juges qui leur
disaient qu'ils pouvaient pas incarcéré
on ne sait pas si valérie pécresse ici
en pleine partie de pétanque tir une
chose est sûre elles pointent toujours à
une décevante 5e place dans les sondages
allez on termine avec l'info de la
journée philippe poutou qui annonce un
face à face avec emmanuel macron ce que
le président candidat a toujours refusé
poisson d'avril évidemment voilà c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
lundi
[Musique]
voilà et un coup d'oeil au sondage du
jour selon celui d'ipsos l'écart se
resserre encore au premier tour entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen crédité
respectivement de 26 et demi pour cent
et de 20% des intentions de vote jean
luc mélenchon et à 16% eric zemmour à
11% valérie pécresse à neuf et demi pour
cent
pas grand chose ne bouge non plus chez
les petits candidats fabien roussel à 3%
jean lassalle à deux et demi et philippe
poutou à 1% et puis au second tour
emmanuel macron l'emporterait avec 54%
des voix marine le pen serait à 46% donc
exactement marion le même écart qui r
c'est une caractéristique de la
présidentielle française à chaque
scrutin parmi les candidats il y à des
candidats trotskistes oui marion une
sorte de tradition ininterrompue depuis
2002 alors on a failli y en avoir trois
ils sont finalement deux candidats à
l'extrême gauche et c'est déjà pas
commun si l'on compare avec les grandes
démocraties occidentales il ya donc
nathalie arthaud pour lutte ouvrière et
philippe poutou du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste ils en sont tous les
deux à leur troisième campagne à chaque
fois leurs scores et dérisoire mais le
scrutin présidentiel leur permet
d'exposer avec force leurs idées et de
tenter d'influencer le débat reportage
signé maya anaïs hayat again et fenil
bayat on s'est battu pour ça une salle
bien calme pour des idées radicales le
plus mais pas sans fond du coup les
contradictions profondes du système
capitaliste ont ressurgi deux fois
candidat à la présidentielle olivier
besancenot a frôlé à chaque fois à la
barre symbolique des 5% désormais ce
facteur de profession fait campagne pour
envoyer pour la première fois à l'elysée
un ouvrier au chômage si li pou tout
s'est donc pas un politicien
professionnel et lui il sait de quoi il
parle quand il parle de
de ce que signifient les conditions
d'existence de travail de millions de
personnes sans que il ya un petit staff
au tour pour lui expliquer voilà comme
de nombreux responsables politiques sont
capables de faire alors qu'ils
connaissent même pas en réalité nos vies
quotidiennes olivier besancenot se
réclament du trotskisme la doctrine
prônée par léon trotsky le théoricien de
la révolution permanente et de la lutte
des classes sans concession
singularité française un ou deux
candidats s'en réclame à chaque
présidentielle depuis 1969 comme alain
krivine figure de mai 68
la présidentielle leur permet de
diffuser plus largement leur message ils
ne veulent pas tant gagné l'elysée que
faire perdre le capitalisme ma mission
c'est qu'on n'a pas gagné ben on est là
pour faire peser notre notre combat est
montré que on pourra y arriver un jour
par les luttes et par la force enfin le
monde ce monde de destruction et
de chacun pour soi quoi la politique
doit être reprise par par les
travailleurs c'est eux qui ont dans les
mains les outils vraiment pour renverser
la capitale parce qu'ils savent c'est
quoi la vraie vie et ils peuvent s'en
emparer et prendre les bonnes décisions
politiques
l'autre visage du trotskisme cl nathalie
arthaud de lutte ouvrière gagner sa vie
est une nécessité pour tous pour sa
troisième participation
elle espère battre son record de
0,64 pour cent bien loin des près de 6 %
recueillis par arlette laguiller six
fois candidate travailleuses
travailleurs oui je m'adresse à vous en
particulier en 2002 la gauche
révolutionnaire avait cumulé près de 10%
des voix les tracts trouvait à l'époque
davantage preneur
mais les militants persiste dans le
froid et le vent au nom des travailleurs
gradé lui fournir jambes
travailleur
l'inflation des prix augmente pas que
les salaires augmentent voilà on n'y a
pas de raison que ce soit les
travailleurs qui payent la crise et qui
paye la guerre économique que se mènent
les grandes entreprises faire toujours
plus de profits pour toujours arroser
leurs actionnaires toujours plus les
militants appellent à un vote de
conviction premier tour qui ne serait
qu'une étape dans un combat bien plus
large on se sent pas seul et au moins le
dimanche on n'a pas de regrets on
discute avec des gens qui sont tentés
par le vote mélenchon qui leur dit avec
moi vous aurez pas besoin de manifester
leur dise il y aura besoin de manifester
que vous voulez qu'on fasse est donc
c'est un peu une arnaque même s'il
existe des différences idéologiques
entre partis trotskystes aucune
animosité perceptible entre les
militants pour eux les votes nathalie
arthaud et philippe poutou
s'additionnent en 2017 les deux
candidats avaient cumulé près de 630
niveau
et c'est maintenant l'heure de notre
module vu d'ailleurs on s'intéresse
aujourd'hui à l'espagne comment
voit-elle cette présidentielle française
oui la présidentielle en france
s'intéresse naturellement en espagne
étant donné la proximité géographique
entre les deux pays les liens
historiques qui les unit c'est leur rôle
au sein de l'union européenne on en
parle ce soir avec erika olavarria
journaliste sur la chaîne hispanophone
de france 24 au l' erika au large
donc vous êtes
d'origine chilienne mais vous connaissez
très bien espagne vous avez travaillé
durant une dizaine d'années en tant que
journaliste en espagne les espagnols
s'intéresse effectivement à cette
campagne présidentielle en france depuis
le début d'heure oui même avant en dépit
septembre quant à nivelles où elle a
annoncé sa candidature
on sait pas ce qu'elle est une femme
mais surtout parce qu'elle est d'origine
espagnole même les journal sportif as
annoncé avait titré sur sa une in
espagnole candidate à la prescience
défense avec une fierté parce que
justement c'est une femme espagnole les
journal s'est rappelé des sites meeting
ce meeting de lancement de la capitale
hidalgo à rouen quand elle avait raconté
qu'elle était la fille de l'électricien
décale x dans le sud de l'espagne mais
aussi la petite fille d'un républicain
qui avait été condamné à mort par les
franquisme mais aussi le journal était
très réaliste et ses souvenirs cette
époque là anne hidalgo avait 1 9% des
préférences d'intentions de vote
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est beaucoup
moins donc l'espagnol aussi s'est posé
la question cette crise dès la gauche
française mais surtout sur cette presse
qui disparition du parti socialiste à la
tête du gouvernement espagnol
aujourd'hui c'est le socialiste pedro
sanchez quel regard est ce que espagnols
portent sur l'état de la gauche en
france c'est un problème et il
s'inquiète parce qu ils toujours les
espagnols ils ont eu un père complexe et
des seules les espagnoles vis à vis
c'est vois s'enfoncer il les trouvait
toujours plus progressistes ça se trouve
que dans la pratique parfois c'est pas
c'est pas vrai par exemple le mariage
pour tous le congé paternel mais vont
toujours ils regardent et la france
comment tu perds pied comme un pays
pardon très progressiste et souvenais
dès l'époque de mitterrand mais
maintenant il se rend compte qu'ils et
comment ce que c'est possible qu'ils
vont ces pays ils puissent pas avoir un
gouvernement de gauche tandis que les
espagnols sont leurs gouvernements dans
une coalition pour des monstres pedro
sanchez justement c'est ça qui est
analysé et le diario punto est celle
diallo point s est il trouver la racine
des sites crise de la gauche dont lé
quinquennat des françois hollande dans
cette brèche qui a eu entre les social
démocrates et la gauche vers la gauche
et or si ils disent que c'est là qu'ils
se sont divorcés 17 électorale électorat
pendant qu'ils avaient donné la victoire
aux 1981 mais comment est-ce que les
espagnols voient maintenant là la forte
progression de l'extrême droite en
france paris s'inquiète parce que bon
c'est pas du tout un phénomène nouveau à
parce qu on sait qu évoque celui parti
d'extrême droite il est rentré dans lé
parlement espagnol en 2019 mais il
trouve bizarre c'est double visage de
l'extrême droite marine le pen d'un côté
et aussi eric zemmour de l'autre côté
alors ils se disent maintenant il y à
une partie de l'électorat d'extrême
droite qui ne votait pas par marine le
pen parce qu'ils avaient honte de voter
pour cette femme qui était un pays n'y
entre mais par contre ils ont le courage
de voter pour ses candidats un peu plus
cultivé même si lui il interprète
l'histoire à sa façon et c'est pour ça
qu'ils votent mais emmanuel macron
c'était aussi un phénomène en 2017 cette
année ne veulent pas la seule chose qui
intéresse des manomètres ans et son
esprit bout de piste parce que les
espagnols ce sont des héros piste merci
mourir erika pour ce point de vue
espagnol donc sur la campagne
présidentielle et je rappelle que les
épisodes de votre road trip consacré la
présidentielle auquel vous avez
participé sur est toujours visible sur
le site internet de france 24 donc en
espagnol mais également en français en
anglais et en arabe et c'est tout pour
ce soir mario remercia toutes les deux
et la fin de france 2022 l'heure du
choix retrouver aussi sur notre site
internet france 24 points com ainsi que
sur les réseaux sociaux on est resté
avec nous marquent une courte pause on
se retrouve juste après
[Musique]